willkommen zu einem neuen blog nach
ungefähr sechs monaten habe ich mich
dazu entschlossen euch nun wieder ein
bisschen mitzunehmen es stehen super
super spannende projekt aber ich hätte
mir jetzt noch schnell die haare und
dann geht es auch schon los wir werden
nämlich ein wohnzimmer bekommen für alle
die es nicht so mitbekommen haben die
wohnung wird erweitert dhl mit aktuell
eine wohnküche wo in der küche ein so
versteht auch über freue ich mich riesig
auf die projekt ich habe gedacht wie
perfekt ist es jetzt wieder mit dem
bloggen anzufangen und parallel jetzt
zum start meines blogs habe ich euch auf
instagram gefragt ob er mir so ein paar
in frage stellen möchte doch ein
bisschen quatschen sollen und da gehe
ich jetzt mal auf eine handvoll fragen
ein gucken und sie mir also spannend
geschrieben habt welche kameraausrüstung
hatte die am anfang so witzig und man
sich das mal reinziehen
angefangen haben wir mit einem iphone 6
ganz ganz lange monate lang hatten wir
ein iphone 6 14 euro ein stativ gekauft
ganz ganz günstiges oft boxen und haben
einfach gestartet und das kasse ist ihr
habt uns damals schon so gefeiert für
unsere qualität und ich war es nicht
einfach daran wie macht man das welche
perspektiven gibt man sich mühe mit dem
schnitt oder füllt man einfach nur stumm
von oben das ist einfach so wichtig
welche techniken man dann beim film
benutzt vor sechs leute so krass und
irgendwie habe ich natürlich angefangen
richtige equipment zu kaufen aber dazu
musste man sich ja auch erst das geld
fällt die thema jobs habe ich gesehen
kamen ganz auf die nachfrage nur kurz im
background wir haben im moment nur für
den online-shop 24 mitarbeiter und die
sollen alle nur dafür dass die pakete
vernünftig ankommt liebe verpackt werden
schnell bei euch an kommen und alles
andere also youtube im endeffekt
eigentlich nur hamza und ich bin immer
noch ich die vor der kamera steht die
die rezepte entwickelt die uns alles
aufschreibt und das ist sehr hamza der
das ganze filmt und schneidet und jobs
im sinne von ja doch wir haben zb eine
übersetzerin
da haben wir noch einen job zu vergeben
übersetzungen von videos bayerin ihr
übersetzten könnt ins türkische zum
beispiel gerne auch ins spanische
schaut man einfach mal eure sprache und
vielleicht auch muttersprachen
vorschreibt mir das dann einfach unten
an die e-mailadresse bewerbung mit
sketchen de und da meldet sich dann
einer von uns bei euch und dann das wäre
sonst jobangebot und wenn uns ähnliche
jobs aus stehen dann melde ich mich sehr
gerne in city of internal immer wie es
bei uns im lager zugeht ist es auch eine
super super schöner atmosphäre wie schön
das bei uns so viele menschen arbeiten
die alle kunterbunt sind und alle
verschiedene religionen und fällt
ansicht haben das ist unserem prinzip
total egal hauptsache die machen die
arbeit gut und das paket kommt mit ganz
viel liebe bei euch an und mit ganz viel
herzblut woher kennst du hamza und sind
eure familie befreundet ich kenne hamza
durchs abi ganz so nah wie gemacht ich
habe mich mit verschiedenen schulen
beworben in meiner stadt ich komme aus
herne und wohl tatsächlich aber nur an
dieser einen schule in bochum angenommen
und hineinzulesen diese lange fahrt mit
der bahn und ich hatte gar keinen bock
darauf da meine arbeit zu machen
wie es das schicksal wollte es haben sie
auch durch umwege genau auf diese schule
genau in meine klasse gekommen kam am
ersten tag sogar zu spät und hat sich
dann auch den einzig freien platz
gesetzt und der überleben mir und so
kannst du zu dass du dann irgendwie
befreundet waren haben sie aber auch
immer total lustig und der humor ist
einfach so verpassen wenn irgendein hat
eine clique und unsere familien haben
sich dann irgendwann kennengelernt das
ist auch dass es auch nur ultra heftige
geschichte man könnte eigentlich ein
buch darüber schreiben ich werde ehrlich
zu euch aber mit der zeit erzählt
derzeit wie hat alles angefangen wie im
leben schon jahre vorher in dem einfach
so interesse am backen und kochen
entwickelt habe wir hatten ja das wissen
auch viele die mir auf insgesamt folgen
der fast 20 jahre lang einen kaffee im
familienbetrieb das heißt meine mama war
die chefin und ich habe nach der schule
immer bei ihr
geguckt was die macht war voll
interessiert bei ihren der küche im café
geguckt wie sie dann die torten zu
bereiten und dann habe ich natürlich um
den hansa kinder ja und er voll davon
profitiert weil er ist also sich gemacht
habe immer mega lecker fand und jetzt
kommt der knackpunkt ich hätte dann so
august september 2006 dann hatte ich
dann okay ich hab nämlich und das
eigentlich jetzt erst einmal direkt auf
youtube in die kamera
eine verteilungs störung wodurch dann
eine op machen musste und quasi drei
wochen ich hab's nicht so schnell
verkauft ich konnte drei wochen gar
nicht klar also dass es gar nicht laufen
erst dann konnte ich gar nicht richtig
laufen und danach die nächsten zwei
wochen nur mit richtig fetten
muskelkater in den beinen ich bin wie
sonova gelaufen das könnt ihr euch gar
nicht vorstellen
und irgendwann dann mir so die decke auf
den kopf gefallen haben hat mich
natürlich mcafee com ist das doch ein
youtube video drehen was es so braucht
es müssten auch andere leute sehen und
dann weiß ich erst mal so'n mainz
gekommen machen wird einfach was war das
erste youtube-video wir erinnert sich
schreibt mir jetzt rein ohne
nachzugucken übrigens leute nur weil ich
auch unbewusst in frenzel weil ich ja
hier auch zum beispiel das reisen von
seifen benutze ich versöhne sprich jetzt
keine empfehlung dafür auswärts einfach
uv p 500 euro viel zu teuer ist für die
leistungen die er bringt trotzdem
benutze ich ihn meist von hansa bekommen
vor über einem halben jahr zum
hochzeitstag geschenkt bekommen hat weil
ich einfach auch fan vom da ist ein
erwerb bin aber vom glätteisen wenn ich
ganz ehrlich bin ich kein fan weil es
einfach
preis leistung stimmt da meiner meinung
nach nicht weil der akku schneller geht
so ich würde sagen die schweiz ihre die
restaurants cafés noch aus und dann
packen wir in hamburg und ganz kurz mal
die baustelle an wie es aktuell aussieht
und dann gucken wir uns um groß irgendwo
ins lange eck einschoss finden jetzt
zeigen sich aber erstmal die baustelle
und zwar gehen wir dafür durch diese
wand und hier ist die baustelle hier
sind wir gerade unseren zukünftigen
bogen
heute war tschuldigung probe später
klaus ne-yo mache ich hier sind wir
gerade im wohnzimmer und ihr könnt nicht
viel erkennen aber ich wollte einfach
mal zeigen wie es hier aussieht und
nebenan befindet sich dann dass
zukünftige arbeiten büro das ist dann
hinter mir leute kennt ihr diese
herzzerreißenden videoclips von damals
stellen es einfach mal
[Musik]
das
unser mann angesprochen aber nicht so
ihr müsst euch vorstellen haben da
vergisst immer seine maske einmal zu
kaufen ist schon ist ein integriertes
schon garantiert also wir entscheiden
uns auf jeden fall irgendein warmen ton
mehr schon noch in der wohnung also eine
restlichen wohnung und wohnzimmer soll
warm werden
wie ist egal hauptsache südlich also ich
finde den ton sehr sehr schön schaut mal
so großes laminat so große flächen finde
ich auch total schön im vergleich jetzt
zu diesem schmalen sieht auch total edel
aus heute bekomme ich richtig flashbacks
meine alte küche ich liebe das design
übrigens immer noch wir leisten diese
ganz großen breiten leisten die sind so
wirklich aus müsste ich immer genau
passende leisten nehmen diese richtig
hohen weißen richtig hübsch oder das
wird der boden der ist eigentlich total
warm aber durch die kamera zudem sind
kalt aus und dazu richtig schönen dicke
leisten dicke weiße leisten und dachte
ja so war der moment wenn man sich
verliert komme eben jaja da wo du kannst
ohne nicht stehen gelassen hast die im
mittleren gang
[Musik]
leute soll ich noch kekse backen
ich weiß es nicht solche dass ich nicht
ist es schon gleich das ist gleich 10
uhr und ich weiß wie wichtig zu backen
so ich mache es einfach ich habe schon
geschütze an ich will subway cookies
banken weil ich mach jannis abwehrreihe
jetzt super gerne di resta ritchies
katys mache ich glaube nicht dass im
subway restaurants katie weißer
schokolade ich kopiere ja nicht
irgendein rezept und macht dann falsch
und daher habe ich mich jetzt
entschlossen entweder häufig software an
frag einfach oder ich war direkt da hin
so haben sie ist hier gerade am
schneiden aha
was ist das denn hier das ist ein
leckerer kuchen
hier stellt haben sie gerade noch das
video aber kombiniert bekommt von uns
die besucher kommen
[Musik]
also ganz ehrlich im internet steht 23
uhr
ganz ehrlich leute da kommt richtig dass
man in mir aus weil 23 uhr heißt 13 7
ist gerade mal 22 25 ich habe eine frage
und zwar plakaten sollte dürfte bis 23
uhr ok alles klar gekommen ich sofort
danke ich war ja super nette leute wir
sind einfach mal nach essen gefahren
quer über die autobahn und das hier hat
laut internet auch bis 23 uhr geöffnet
subway so richtig voll zehn minuten vor
feierabend nur die hausmesse getroffen
tschuldigung nur ne kurze frage haben
sie noch cookies da okay als da sind die
auf
ich habe jetzt zwei mal restauriert und
zweimal probiert
wir probieren leute ganz ehrlich soll
die hektik das rezept das original sein
dass man dieses lied schon noch groß
dass manche ja das sieht nach weißer
schokolade auch die erstmals jetzt mal
spannend weil man ganz genau auf deine
sinne hörst dann merkst du denn tritt
dieses total cheesecake automatisches
gehört auch nicht wirklich aber ich war
das hat der konsistenz und wer dabei ist
mit nichts oder mach ich wollte euch
heute noch backen nicht bock hatte aber
schon zwölf asse stehen dann morgen
richtig schön frech filme mit unserem
namen von premier wies das video dazu
und ich glaube wir hätten die im block
an der stelle
super das restaurant kommt dann müssen
sich wegen nachmachen klicken und
sollten unbedingt ihr seht ihr die bühne
das ein rezept stand man sich macht und
am ende kommt ein video aus essen
gefragt was krank ist teuer
ja ein bisschen wir auswärts immer
wieder anklingen nachdem ein name zocken
sind dann dass die hände sich verdient
gelassen gerne unser leid in den
kommentaren teilen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten videos haben sie schon seinen
eigenen welt